but uh on the topic of merchants of
death uh i heard hillary clinton's in
the news too
yes yes all right so uh but we got to be
we got to be careful this one i'm not a
fan of the conspiracy theories to be
honest
we have this story from 11 alive it came
out over the weekend you may have seen
it
alabama anchor who broke bill clinton
loretta lynch tarmac story is dead at 45
of an apparent suicide now if you're not
familiar with the story basically bill
clinton had a meeting with then attorney
general loretta lynch on a plane
and hillary clinton was under
investigation and the investigation gets
dropped then they bring it back up
and this forced loretta lynch to recuse
herself because of a conflict of
interest
this reporter christopher sein then went
on to write a book about it
and this was promoting it last year on
like fox news this was back in what was
it 2016 when this story 2016.
when hillary clinton was running to be
president of the united states
and now i'll tell you this first and
foremost i i think the conspiracy theory
is silly
but people are pointing out the
conspiracy theory called the clinton
body count
where they're saying like look at all
these people connected to the clinton's
own man and
so many have died and i gotta say i just
think it's bs i really really do
absolutely first of all let me just
point out in this story first with
respect to the guy's family
i i really don't like the idea that this
guy he's got family and kids
he was an anchor and now people you know
bring up conspiracy theories
but you know what people are a lot of
talk on the internet people are allowed
to ask questions they're
if they see patterns they're allowed to
ask questions about it and then we got
to investigate
this guy report on a story five years
ago five five years ago
a little bit longer than five years ago
why why if if there really was a
conspiracy what's clinton like i will
wait five years and then get my revenge
now oh yeah but but his book was just
released a year ago so
and that could have been the threat but
he said
he said that last year and he said the
threats have started
ever since he released that story he
also talked about
how he had to move his family not
multiple times
because of these threats he had three
young children he had a wife
he was 46 years old prominently pretty
young again
i'm not here jumping on any conclusions
i'm not going to tell you what happened
i'm not going to
say this happened exactly i'm just
saying some of the preliminary data
and information this is somewhat causing
a chilling effect and a lot of people
are bringing up the fact that you know
hillary clinton's the clintons they
don't play by the rules
they're corrupted they were never held
accountable for their corruption
and who knows i mean another thing that
really kind of comes to mind
right now is bill clinton coming out and
saying that the
the netflix series house of cards is 99
and in house of cards in the first
season they assassinate and kill
journalists
let me point this out what we're talking
about is the clinton body count
conspiracy there's 46 people
on that list but it's not correct so of
course
so so hold on this this guy was getting
death threats
totally believe it this sounds more like
left its extremists
who don't get held accountable who are
mad at the sky because they believe he
contributed to hillary clinton's loss
if the if the clintons were involved
they're not going to send him warnings
they're going to be like here's an email
just letting you know here's our plan
it's going to you know and look so about
there's this meme that goes around this
poster and it's like here are all the
people the clintons
have been associated with the clintons
who have committed suicide and some of
them are completely it's like
six degrees of kevin bacon it's like he
was an accountant in a firm that once
consulted bill clinton and i'm like come
on
dude so look look look high-profile
political people
are going to have tens or hundreds of
thousands of
of connections with various people and
these things might happen i'll tell you
this
i'm not saying i know for sure i'm
saying i err on the side of
show me the evidence and show me the
proof and i'll look through it for this
i think people jump the gun and the
biggest problem i have with any
conspiracy is
the moment you come out and say ah
clinton body count you've completely
discredit yourself in the eyes of anyone
who would actually do an investigation
anybody who would actually be who should
hear or ask questions or
if you want to inform people and you
come out you jump to the to the
conclusion
people are going to say okay you're nuts
what you say is hey
this guy was reporting on the clintons
this guy put out a big story
maybe he was working on another story he
was getting death threats
i think we should investigate it beyond
the claims of an apparent suicide stop
right there that's where we need to go
we do the investigation
but you know what i'll tell you this man
people need to understand
that the majority of premeditated murder
is never solved
the majority yeah majority in illinois i
think it's like 53
so it's like they actually do a really
good job of tracking down a decent
amount but
most of it they can't solve i i agree
with you we shouldn't be jumping to
conclusions at least
there should be an investigation uh and
but but you know there's some you know
serious questions that need to be asked
here
and i think i think every suicide is
investigated anyway so it should it
should be
the police are investigating this right
uh and then
as far as the the clinton body count
there was uh i think nbc las vegas
actually printed the the name of of the
list uh and then you know people who are
on
cbs cbs i think it was like barry seal
vince foster seth rich so again
as as you said doesn't causation does
not prove
you know correlation does not prove
causation doesn't mean it's true at
least we should investigate it
but uh you know you know i think the
clintons
should be investigated hillary clinton
is the vhs casino from the ring
you're going out i'll make something
very simple for you if you come to me
and you say tim hillary clinton is an
evil
evil woman who would not stop at killing
to push her political agenda you know
what i'm gonna say to you
muammar gaddafi yeah but foreign policy
is very difficult
he died exactly but foreign policy is
very different from a local journalist
in alabama who five years ago reported
on a story
came out the book last year i really
doubt someone was like i'll get my
revenge
five years later i just don't see it i
don't you know what i think
often when it comes to conspiracies
people overlook simple solutions
sure let me i'm trying to be respectful
this guy's family but you know
with the people spreading the story
around i want to address it
here's a guy who broke one of the
biggest stories
in history five years ago a few years
later he writes a book
about the same story he broke four years
ago it's like
do you got anything else for us so now
maybe a year after the book
did it sell well maybe it didn't i don't
know maybe this guy
got to touch a piece of the sky and then
after five years he could not recreate
that moment
and maybe he got depressed he wouldn't
he he got he got he got to see over the
clouds you know what i mean yeah it's
it's not impossible
i i always like to look at the reporting
on what his co-workers had to say and
i saw some i read some tweets today that
they were saying you know this feels
surreal
i was just cutting it up with him in the
office last night they were surprised
this is what you can't get carried away
with that's normal for suicides
but also yeah i get death threats you
know as well and let's acknowledge i bet
you'd probably get that threats as well
let's acknowledge this don't worry
about it let's be intellectually going
to be intellectually honest let me talk
about i'm going to reserve i'll get it
i'll get it coming i'm going to live to
be 100 years old
yeah i uh i'm gonna eat eat right and
i'm gonna be very
i'm very happy life's great the business
is booming you know i got my friends
here we're hanging out
never been happier i am not suicidal
at all for the record here uh testifying
in front of everyone i'll put my hand on
the bible if i have to
uh i love my life and i love uh
i love uh you know doing what i do but i
ever commit suicide
investigate hillary clinton
but this was a major story this did have
a huge impact on the elections
i think anything's possible here but but
i want to be again try to be respectful
to the family members
uh you know the the young children the
wife the friends uh
it's really up to them to speak here on
this matter i don't want to speak too
much on it
and i think at least there should be
more investigations and and it does set
a chilling effect so i do think that
this is possible do i have the smoking
gun do i have the proof absolutely not
i don't claim to have but i think it is
possible that this happened because it
does set a chilling effect
that scares some people and i think it's
bro i think it's probable but but we
could be simple
i think possible yeah but what's what's
possible it's possible for you to do a
backflip right now and then break your
neck and fall it's also possible from
the fall too listen exactly
anything's possible you you can track
youtube
breakdowns youtube mental breakdowns all
you got to do is look at
look at a youtuber track their views
over the month
and the moment you see a small dip in
their views will protest precipitate a
video where they're like i just can't do
this anymore but i can't it's too rough
not kidding you'll watch their views and
something will happen where their views
dropped from like a million per video
down to like 800 down to 500
and then also the video drops i'm
quitting i can't take it anymore because
what happens is they touch the sky and
they touch the sky and then every video
after that is them getting lower and
lower and start panicking saying
why can't i reach that anymore i saw
what was up there i saw
the beautiful reality and then they
break down and they do these videos
where they cry
and they're like it's just too you don't
know how stressful it is struggling
every day and it's like
sometimes there are cycles in viewership
you got to calm down
but i've seen people lose their minds
lose their cool quit their channels
freak out
now you got a guy who with all due
respect he was a local anchor
and he comes out this is this is a big
jump he went from being a local anchor
to the biggest story probably in the
world
affecting political outcomes not only
that imagine he's saying he's getting
death threats
imagine how much awful stuff was sent to
him every day by these democrats
saying like you are scum you are violent
he reads it every day i'm sure
it was breaking him down yeah and and
he's being accused of being responsible
for
orange hitler for the past four years by
these nutcases yeah
blue and on types so yeah i can
understand the pressure that he was
under
it's just that just seems it could be
dude it could be both but but there's a
reason that the most amount of
sociopaths are in washington dc
per capita and a lot of politicians are
cold-blooded killers that literally
bring back slavery to africa you know
and and
and they don't even care about it see
here's what happens hillary clinton
kills muammar gaddafi not just that no
no hold on hillary clinton says
about julia sanchez can't we just drone
the guy oh that was a joke apparently
when you get a politician who laughs in
the face
of war with russia over the no-fly zone
in syria
people are going to go ahead and assume
that the simple solution is that she's a
lunatic who kills people
yeah i still don't i i just think it's
like why would this why would a super
villain like muck their hands up
in the nitty-gritty that matters nothing
you know what i mean unless
unless he's doing further research on
the story i i don't know i can't even i
can't even theorize honestly i
i think it's important for people's
worldview to see politicians as
sociopathic
globalist clowns with a monopoly of
violence in my own personal opinion
that's just my own personal perspective
here's the truth you don't need a
clinton body count to hate the clintons
there's plenty of evidence there's
plenty of
corruption destroyed people in the
middle east because of the jews too so
could you imagine if there was like
a uh you know like a secretary of state
who ran a foundation that took
hundreds of millions of dollars from
foreign governments while they were
secretary of state i mean
like that couldn't possibly happen in
this country could it or hang out with
you know
the likes of jeffrey epstein and ditch
secret service and jump on the
i can't even say it the express uh
airplane
that they did with kevin spacey kevin
spacey also another person i i'd like to
bring these
things up because i think they're worth
it they're worth considering the spacey
body camera
but kevin spacey also has three people
that came out against him and accused
him of horrible things that we can't
mention in here on this youtube channel
when they were small children when they
were small children
they came out and said kevin spacey did
unspeakable things to them
three people who did that uh are dead as
well
uh kevin spacey you know house of cards
bill clinton i don't know
you can make a lot of jumps and
assertions here i'm not trying to do
that i'm just saying
uh you know there's a reason there's so
many sociopaths this is what you
you got to be careful for right so i was
we had matt brainer on the show he's the
guy who's doing uh uh he was doing the
voter integrity project
and uh he's doing now look at look at
america as that is
so you know one of the things he says is
that when it comes to like election
issues
you get a lot of these silly lawsuits
that muck up the system and make it
really hard for the actual hard like
investigatory work and
reform work to fix these systems and
find you know fix these problems
that's why i'm very much like you start
with the evidence you have
and you seek in evidence and then you
find the conclusion when people come out
and they decide
i know it's this story it actually makes
it very difficult to
actually get an investigation or to to
solve whatever actually happened in this
regard i think people should need to
realize
we don't live in a movie i think
people's view of the world is very very
tainted by movies and i'll give you a
really simple explan
example silencers like people in big
cities don't think about guns literally
believe there's a thing you can screw
onto a gun and go pew pew pew
not a thing doesn't exist they believe
it so when it comes to these conspiracy
theories
it's like you got to understand how much
of your worldview is tainted by movies
to think this stuff is possible like go
out
i tell you man go out to an actual
conflict urban conflict or war
it is so much different than these
people that anybody realizes because
movies tank their view of the world
i keep thinking about uh putin and i
think it was like five years ago
one of his political opponents was in a
car driving in moscow and they got
stopped on the street and dudes got out
and just shot him today on video yeah
yeah and so like in the united states
there's a lot of like death by suicide
we don't really hear of a political
opponent getting gunned down in their
car in the middle of the day in the
united states
but that doesn't mean it's not people
aren't getting killed for their politics
it's just saying we don't see that
blatant so when putin says ashley
babbitt was at an assassination no dude
when someone gets gunned down in their
car in the middle of the day that's
running against you
politically that's an assassination when
someone's trespassing
and gets killed that's not an
assassination
so don't be clear about that it was a
killing yeah it could be it's declared a
murder still should be
more investigated and there still should
be some repercussions for an officer
who shot an unarmed woman i'm i'm just
waiting for the people that are
interested in ending police brutality
yeah to have anything to say about
ashley babbitt
that would be amazing if you guys could
just have one thing to say about her
an unarmed woman shot in the neck at
point blank range we don't even know the
guy's name still i mean
am i the only one that's bothered by
this i don't know well what was it when
it's an insurrectionist
okay so the other issue is we've been
having an ongoing insurrection from the
far left for
for a long time now it's like i don't
even think it's fair to say a year
because it's been going on long before
that
when they would show up to a trump rally
and start attacking people throwing
explosives and beating people
when when were the democrats ever going
to come out oh i'm sorry they said it
was an
idea jerry nadler oh it's just an idea
it's not real then you get
you like joy or and read or whatever
coming out and defending
saying you know antifa oh they're not
they're not bad people they're good guys
they're antifa it's just
the media absolutely protects them
here's what i'll say
they come out and they're like
republicans keep saying that it was just
tourists on on the sixth
and i'm like okay that's dumb i don't
care there were dumb people rioting on
the six
antifa was bad as well they riot but the
media acts like the only people who
exist
are like three republicans who say dumb
things that's it
and then everyone else's voice is shut
out from the argument yep
and and everybody that protests for
black lives matter whether they burn
stuff or kill people
they're good and if you go to the
capitol and you uh
you know get a little bit aggressive
with your protesting
you're you are a terrorist and should
spend the rest of your years and get
yeah well they get bailed out
too yeah well that's a yeah a lot of
like blowing up
private property didn't seem to bother
people but as soon as it was public
property like government property they
went
if you remember last season last summer
they were talking about
you have insurance what are you upset
about you know that that was really
people's attitude they were like of
course if you built
if you have to burn down a building to
get people to pay attention to your
cause
even if it's not a police precinct it's
a it's just some
corner store that's owned by probably a
black person in the neighborhood
it's i mean it's just the uh it's an
excuse
they don't actually want to defend the
people who live there they just need an
excuse for when someone comes asking
sure hey why did you guys burn down that
small corner store
they got insurance okay that's it give
me an answer
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8 pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time